good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight we're going to have
updates for you in a moment on the New
FBI censorship Scandal as well as the
cia's involvement in the Kennedy
assassination 59 years ago which is now
confirmed it's all real
but first because it's Friday and we're
in a Sentimental Mood we'd like to take
a moment to say goodbye to one of our
all-time favorite members of Congress Mr
Adam kinzinger of Kankakee Illinois
ladies and gentlemen Kinser was first
elected to the house 12 years ago and
for the bulk of his time in office he
served utterly without distinction in
Virtual anonymity a few of his
constituents had heard of him but none
expressed interest in learning more
then in 2018 came the transformation
that was the year that Adam kinzinger
turned 40 and things began to change
inside of him
the first signs were subtle but
unmistakable choking up but a car
insurance commercial opening an
Instagram account and posting pictures
of himself wearing Spandex bike shorts
to Starbucks without shame and sometimes
with a fanny pack
by 2021 kinzinger had a full-blown case
of male menopause with all the familiar
painful symptoms mood swings hot flashes
food cravings uncontrollable weeping a
lesser man would have retreated from
public life chosen new pronouns and
transitioned in private but Adam
kinzinger chose another path he chose to
be a role model he wanted other
middle-aged men to know there is life
after hormonal imbalance
and so on July 27 2021 Adam kittensinger
bravely came out of the closet as a
weepy man you may remember the moment
I never expected a day to be quite as
emotional for me as it has been
but you guys won
you guys help
you know democracies are not defined
by our bad days
imagine the courage that took yes I am
emotionally incontinent
yes I am utterly irrational no I will
not be silent
in Washington kinsiger's performance was
considered deeply inspirational here's a
man who has no control of himself at all
so we'd better put him in charge of
important things Kinser quickly became
regarded as an essential voice on
foreign policy when the world hangs in
the balance you want a guy who cries a
lot
for his part kinsinger demonstrated a
remarkability to make any situation on
the planet no matter how complex or
weighty All About Him diplomacy by
narcissism
here he was yesterday on the house floor
in his final yes emotion-laden address
history has proven that American
isolation from the world affairs is
dangerous
over the years I've been privileged to
lead the effort on supporting American
leadership in a world drowning in foe
strongmen
advocating for the rights of Syrian men
women and children to live without fear
of Assad's death squads shouldn't be
political this is simply the right thing
to do
advocating for stronger American
assistance in Ukraine to counter Putin's
illegal Invasion shouldn't be political
that's just the right thing to do
yeah it's just the right thing to do see
the world actually isn't complicated in
fact the world is simple it's like an
original made for TV movie on Lifetime
the kind where you burn through two bags
of skinny pop just trying to keep your
tears in check
so if Adam kinsiger is doing something
in a foreign country with Guns by
definition it's quote just the right
thing to do like in Syria kinzinger's
often express concern for Syria's men
women and children is what matters and
because that concern matters so much
kinzinger has pushed hard to continue
the neocon proxy war in Syria results
Syria now has no economy left and
there's a massive cholera outbreak in
progress men women and children are
dying in huge numbers because it's just
the right thing to do
same in Ukraine Kinsler made that clear
the other day when he responded
personally to a Twitter account called
cat turd because when you're one of
Washington's leading authorities on
foreign policy you spend a lot of time
on Twitter reading accounts with names
like catterd so the other day cat turd
made the mistake of posting a meme that
seemed to mock the colors of the
Ukrainian flag colors that are sacred to
Adam kinziger and every other empathetic
soccer monitor from mid-40s you can
imagine how offensive that was it was
like telling an off-color joke about
Meghan Markle it could not stand
and so alone in battling debilitating
hot flashes in his kitchen fighting the
urge to open yet another bag of Chips
Ahoy Adam kinzinger fought back literal
evil he wrote in a late night response
to cat turd
if I met you in person it would not end
well for you sicko
whoa hear that cat turd it will not end
well for you
that's not a pillow fight Adam kinziger
is talking about that's a full-on slap
fight with hair pulling this is real
you'd better apologize
our heart goes out to cat turd tonight
Who's probably cowering in a litter box
somewhere waiting for Adam kinziger to
show up with sharpened Nails mock the
Ukrainian flag get scratched those the
rules cat turd it's a tough Town meow
but speaking of how it will all end
how's it going to end for Adam kinsiger
well we suspect it'll end like it began
in anonymity in just weeks Adam Kinser
will be another CNN contributor no one
will ever see him again but we will
never forget him Adam kinzinger will
live forever in our hearts as an example
of what a man can be when he stops
trying to be a man and unleashes the
emotionally fragile divorced single mom
within have another glass of chardonnay
listen to me cry yes Miss kinsiger we
will
so here it is one last time
never expected a day to be quite as
emotional for me as it has been
this morning
you guys help
you know democracies are not defined
by our bad days
[Music]
wow Adam kinzinger see what SoulCycle
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight